la lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
devenu courant un nouveau convoi de
prisonniers afghans a gagné la base de
guantanamo à cuba
particularité de cette enclave
américaine
elle échappe aux lois américaines
justement alors d'après les autorités de
washington lé chat prête aussi à la
convention de genève sur le traitement
des prisonniers
qu'en est il exactement à washington
etienne leenhardt pascal golomer ces
détenus enchaînés cagoulés qui quittent
l'aéroport de gandar doivent-ils être
considérés comme des prisonniers de
guerre et à ce titre sont ils protégés
par la convention de genève qui définit
leurs conditions de détention interdit
toute violence à leur encontre
leur accorde un droit de visite et leur
garantit une protection jury à la
question les états unis répondent qu'un
prisonnier de guerre doit faire partie
d'une armée avoir un uniforme et que
tous ces hommes sont plutôt des
combattants illégaux ces combattants
illégaux
aucun droit en vertu de la convention de
genève notre intention pour la plupart
d'entre eux et de les traiter
raisonnablement selon les termes de
cette convention
en choisissant guantanamo sur l'île de
cuba washington a joué la sécurité la
base américaine n'est même pas
territoire des etats unis
sur le plan juridique la constitution ne
s'y applique donc pas la situation
manque singulièrement de clarté
d'autant que selon les lois de la guerre
on ne peut pas détenir sans procès un
prisonnier au delà de la fin d'un
conflit
l'espagne a annoncé que cette guerre est
vraiment bizarre quand at-elle commencé
quand c'est terminé tél et combien de
temps les états unis détiendront ces
hommes sans les juger et si ce flou
juridique est valable pour les
prisonniers de guantanamo il est aussi
pour les centaines de personnes détenues
ici aux etats-unis depuis plusieurs mois
est tenu au secret par le fbi haïti
attend de décider si elles sont de près
ou de loin lié aux attentats du
11-septembre et d'aprr